God Prince Charles was now in the ABIA
to witness the anointing
it is the most sacred part of a royal
coronation the anointing historically
regarded as a moment between Sovereign
and God
is hidden from cameras and the millions
watching worldwide
70 years on from his mother's coronation
the anointing screen for King Charles
has been completed it will shield the
king as the Archbishop of Canterbury
anoints the sovereign created by 150
students and staff at the Royal School
of needlework the tree design was
personally selected by the Monarch each
Leaf depicting one of the 56 countries
of the Commonwealth
it's been incredible it's been a really
really big team project and I think
that's what's been so lovely about it
because everybody has been able to bring
their skills to this this screen and
it's just been amazing to work with
everybody and collaborate accept our
offering of this anointing screen which
we dedicate this day blessed at a
special service at the chapel Royal at
James's Palace the screen will be
carried by service Personnel from
regiments of the household division
before the crowning of his majesty the
screen is there to actually provide
privacy to the most sacred part of of
the ceremony and previously it was a
canopy over the top which actually
didn't provide real privacy it was more
figurative and now this three-sided
screen provides you know absolute
privacy during the process
ahead of next weekend three new
photographs of the king and the queen
consort have been released taken in the
blue drawing room at Buckingham Palace
it is now down to the fine details and
finishing touches with just days to go
till the ceremony he has waited more
than 70 years for
now why said Sky News